this is worse than two girls one cup
it's sexual but it's also about puck
this is second but two-dimensional air
hockey I don't know how I feel about
that my eyes are watering ha ha ha ha
you'll also think of all the bacteria in
their mouth oh I'm sweating I'm sweating
nothing to be so upset sorry to play a
great game it's called is this chocolate
all right what is it chocolate or oh no
it's a clothes hanger you look like an
idiot
I tend to play this game with everything
is put things in my mouth and like I
wish this was chocolate
gratulations you lost what he is trying
to sing songs I'll get my hands on at
all no he's enjoying his hand job I
think they better have the version where
guys eat girls out while we sing karaoke
where this is bull
this isn't they can't broadcast this
what I want to know is what's going on
with the woman what do you mean like is
she getting paid oh she's getting paid
she's getting paid a handle a good lord
hey she's like this she's like she think
and he says like the good either you
don't come and I assume you get money or
you do come and you got it free HJ while
trying to sing that's true it's really
hard to sing in front of our crowds like
it would be even harder in any mess yo
can you dig I respect the show but I
also find it very disturbing I feel like
if I were to pitch this what would
happen is that everyone would be so both
offended and terrified that no one would
say no to me
the Japanese gave us great things they
gave us like fuel-efficient cars
Nintendo doesn't seem like they have the
same things that are legal and illegal
on TV they're I think America might be a
better place our game shows were like
this yeah I feel like that is the core
issue what's going wrong with politics
with society yeah get economy it would
definitely loosen people up a little bit